hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
friend this is Conan O'Brien what are
you giggling about already because you
tried to play the school marm and shut
us up right before this began and son
and I are snickering away yeah Sona
wouldn't stop talking and we needed to
get the show started and
um here's the problem
Sona when she's talking a lot and you
want her to maybe talk a little less so
that we can get something done okay hold
it listen listen he's got his hands you
go Nick changes the narrative to make
himself look more you go nuclear
reasonable you go nuclear you change The
Narrative to make yourself look more
reasonable you've done this every single
time I'm a reasonable man you're a
criminal you're an absolute criminal and
you need to be killed well listen
that's why we brought you here today do
you notice the plastic on the floor I do
I feel like Joe pescian oh [ __ ] Glam
I'll tell you what was going on before
we started even recording today we got
into a big heated discussion because
um
it feels like there's a generation gap
there is Matt Gourley and I both love to
talk about things uh from the 60s 70s
80s
um and Sona you and not just you but
also Eduardo and Adam you're all from a
different generation and you're
constantly saying what the hell are they
talking about yeah and so this I need to
address this because this Venture this
podcast I I worry are we alienating
people with our old records we're
bringing everybody in because as we've
discussed on this podcast before we're
almost all exactly 10 years apart in
three different Generations Millennial
Generation X and Boomer yeah we're
covering all bases you guys it's not
that you're talking about your
generation either you're talking about
things older than you two like you're
talking about things from the 60s but
you were born in the 60s so I know you
didn't watch that stuff in the 60s when
it aired you like went back and did that
and that's what you do well I want to
say cheating excuse me it's not cheating
my channel generation we're not my
generation and match generation here's
how we're different we're somewhat aware
of things that happened before we were
alive
reading about them wow researching them
attack my generation and every
generation for you for you everything
that happened before
1997 doesn't exist then how do you even
educate yourself with things that are
going on now sure
you won't go forward and you won't go
backward I'm in the middle playing Rover
I speak both you're like no you don't no
you don't okay guess what I listen to
Tamagotchi Pokemon
I know it's happening what
yeah
Sailor Moon no you're equally you guys
are equally as guilty no I do try I do
try to understand the new music I do try
this morning I was listening the new
music
you know the new music how about the new
way people speak about things I dig your
new sound cat
I bought her this is painful I bought a
record this morning
on this one yeah thank you this is this
is how you guys are if you have time
excuse me I'm the guy who uh last summer
went with my daughter to Coachella
checked out Japanese breakfast this
morning I'm listening to wet leg I think
they're terrific I'm I'm I'm trying I'm
making an effort but also I know that
America had a civil war from 18618 and
you you can I know about The Goonies
yeah I do and you know I'm with you on
The Goonies but here's the thing with
you too it's like okay I know what the
Civil War is I know what happened you're
like on this date exactly at this time
this cannon was shot and then that
happened why do you need to know all of
that like why can't I just know big
picture stuff you're you get you're like
you should know what happened on this
date 400 years ago like nobody knows
that stuff you know maybe I maybe I'm
wrong I guess I should but no I didn't
expect it to
you can do what makes you happy see this
Great Peacemaker in the middle
generation who wants to make both people
you know what our you are the child of a
of a couple that fights bitterly uh I am
a child of divorce yeah and you're and
so here I can see it I can see me and
Daddy are fighting again it's happening
all over I'm the child of people that
should have divorced but uh that's a
different thing but you I'm just saying
this is is really fascinating to me that
that uh yeah I saw what you were doing
right there which is no no you're both
right can we just go get ice cream and
everyone's good can we you're a good
mommy and you're a good daddy you both
have photographic memory too about
things but not things that matter you do
you both really remember a lot of
details you remember I've seen from a
show that happened you know 50 years ago
I don't I don't remember would I watched
like two days because you have something
called priorities you have a healthy
understanding of things that are
important in life and we don't right I
didn't expect the conversation I go this
way well I will say because I think you
guys also are have healthy have a
priorities you don't have to don't break
down
this is how you defuse sauna do you
understand that I'm learning I'm
learning from the master yeah only took
you 14 years but
uh I I do think yes it's it's a it's a
struggle but one must stay current one
must stay current it's just and this is
why it's good that you're here Sona and
you Eduardo it's good that you're here
to say we don't know what you're talking
about because I'm sure there are some
listeners out there who if you and I go
on a long run about Smokey and the
Bandit
um are saying uh what are they talking
about classic movie 1977 uh monster Hits
there's just so many good movies there
really aren't there really aren't there
are I think there are a lot of really
really good movies and I think that you
know it's yeah but you have afford to
watch a lot of them especially the ones
that were made along long time ago and
if they're not on a streaming service
what are your favorite movies
I mean I go by genre you know my
favorite comedy is probably Galaxy Quest
I love adaptation I've always loved
these are solid choices yeah oh thanks
you know my favorite rom-com is
Moonstruck you know I I what are your
what are your favorite movies I mean
we're just interested we're not yeah
very offensive and we were actually that
was supposed to be a sweet question I
know I'm sorry I didn't mean that that
got very intense no I thought like one
of your choices was on the money and I
think uh and then the other are just big
swing and a miss also you know what I
came in real revved up on this because
you did it you did the quiet thing to me
right before because you know that
upsets me it does upset you you didn't
that's why I slam hands I do the little
clam hands and I do it because it makes
Sona crazy but you were talking a lot
you were on a roll you wouldn't stop and
then I just do the little Ash and I do
it's uh Dr Evil oh does it remember when
you said yeah can we have a little can
we have a little and um then you just
see red I do and then you you uh you
attack well also before that you looked
at Adam like intervene here and quiet
her up quiet this woman that I would
like to see would someone take me he did
though he looked at you like intervene
here would someone quiet this woman
she's hysterical I get a pail of water
I'm sorry I'm sorry that's what uh by
the way that's what Stanton did when
Lincoln was on his deathbed after being
shot in Ford's Theater see I'm with you
listen Mary Lincoln kept coming into the
room and wailing and screaming and
throwing herself on the body and finally
Stanton of course the Secretary of War
says someone kept this hysterical woman
out of here and they carried her away
from her dying husband why would they do
that because it's Stanton you don't [ __ ]
with him he just prosecuted a war
successfully for four years so he died
he had a massive beard his wife wasn't
even at his bedside probably a good idea
she confidently held up this rap song I
don't understand this this is a
upsetting isn't this upsetting it was a
different time and and Mary she shot him
some got shot right in front of her
she's hysterical I find that it was a
different time uh excuses going over
well these days yes yeah yes and I'd
like to right now say that uh I think
wait a minute no I'm not gonna say any
of that I was gonna do it I was gonna do
it as a joke and then I thought nah
they're gonna just read it as a
transcript at the trial so and then I'm
like you're Anna it's clear that I'm
exaggerating for the for the humorous
content cut to me at a newly opened
Alcatraz prison just for you opened just
for me
and you guys come by on a boat and wave
at me yeah no audience and you're just
walking the island you know you guys are
allowed to like whatever you like I'm
sorry I make fun of you or YouTube
that's not cool of me to do that we're
all friends remember Stanton Secretary
of War giant beard had Mary Lincoln
removed from the uh well of course the
Peterson house remember too if you're
just talking Alcatraz you can watch
Escape from Alcatraz or the rock it
depends on what generation you're Escape
from Alcatraz The Rock